mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
the prolific mathematician oiler asked
this riddle to his students
or so the story goes two farmers
bring a total of 100 eggs to market
each farmer sets an individual price per
egg
the two farmers set different prices
after selling all eggs each farmer
received the same amount of money as
the other the first farmer then remarks
to the second
if i had sold your eggs at my
price i would have gotten a total of 15
coins the second farmer then replies
well if i had sold your eggs
at my price per egg i would have gotten
a total of 20 over three coins
the puzzle is how many eggs did each
farmer sell
i thank francisco from portugal for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem
we will first translate the word problem
into algebraic symbols
suppose the first farmer had x eggs
since there are 100 eggs in total that
means the second farmer would have 100
minus
x eggs the amount of money the first
farmer would get
is equal to the number of eggs x
multiplied by the price of a
per egg this is equal to a times x
the amount of money the second farmer
would get is equal to b
multiplied by the number of eggs 100
minus x
since the two farmers receive the same
amount of money as each other
these two quantities are equal to each
other
the first farmer then remarked if i had
sold your eggs at my price
i would have gotten 15 coins this means
the price of a
multiplied by the quantity of the second
farmer 100 minus
x must be equal to 15.
then the second farmer remarked if i had
sold your eggs at my price
i would have gotten 20 over three coins
this means
b multiplied by x is equal to 20 over 3.
we thus have three equations which we
need to solve for
x from the first equation we'll divide
both sides
by b and both sides by x we thus
solve for the ratio a over b
we then take the third equation and
divide it from the second equation
we thus get the following equation
we can then substitute in the ratio of a
over b
into the second equation the result
is the ratio 100 minus x all over
x is squared we can simplify the
fraction
on the right hand side we then take the
positive square root of both sides
from here we can cross multiply and we
have a linear equation in
x we can systematically solve for x
we thus get that x is equal to 40. now
recall
x is equal to the number of eggs of the
first farmer
and 100 minus x is equal to 60 is the
number of eggs of the second farmer
so the answer is the first farmer had 40
eggs
and the second farmer had 60 eggs
what a neat riddle thanks for making us
one of the best communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
[Music]
you